Ernests doesn't live in the past or the
future he's just there and I learned
quite a lot about the way he and
Vladimir Putin relate to each other you
know the relationship between Putin and
Berlusconi I wrote an article in The
Financial Times called The Odd Couple
because here we have both alpha males
Putin II the former KGB agent
Berlusconi the billionaire media mogul
and it was fascinating to watch the two
of them interacting and see how strong
leaders only really respect other strong
leaders Alan Friedman he's the author of
the new book Berlusconi the epic story
the billionaire who took over Italy
thanks so much
this weekend the c-span cities tour
hosted by our charter communications
cable partners explores the history and
literary culture of Worcester
Massachusetts located approximately 40
miles west of Boston Worcester played a
key role in the American Revolution and
the women's suffrage movement Worcester
was also a major contributor to the
industrial revolution in the US and was
known for its innovators and commerce
and industry on book TV we'll learn
about the life of political philosopher
and politician Henry George who
published progress and poverty in 1879
and then we'll visit the American
antiquarian society one of the largest
repositories in the country of original
books pamphlets and periodicals that are
related to the history of the United
States next we'll talk with author
Jeannette Greenwood and discuss her book
first fruits of freedom about the
migration of African Americans to
Worcester after the Civil War there were
you know anti-slavery organizations in
Worcester almost every town and the
county had one there were lots of as
soon as the war breaks out there are
quite a few Friedman's aid societies
that are organized as well by white
Worcester writes and black Worcester
right so it's it's a city that you know
at this time that's very forward-looking
it's very progressive in lots of ways on
American history TV will visit Mechanics
Hall built in 1857 for members of
Worcester as Mechanics Association the
building is listed in the National
Register of Historic Places it's
originally served as a Learning Center
for its members but also served as a
platform for social and cultural
activities including women's
rallies the first women's rights
convention happened before the hall
opened but afterward most people came
here to speak Worcester was the central
location and Mechanics Hall is where
everything happened if anything happened
in Worcester it happened here in the
hall and finally we'll tour the Clark
University Special Collections of
physicist dr. Robert Goddard is best
known as the father of modern rocketry
will talk with Fordyce Williams and
learn about Goddard's contribution to
science through his papers diaries and
artifacts Robert Goddard attributes his
first interest in space travel and his
first interest in a career in science -
a day in 1899 he went outside with a saw
and a hatchet and he was meant to trim
the dead branches off a cherry tree and
he climbed the tree I think he made
himself a little ladder to get up the
tree and while he was up in the tree he
looked down on the fields around him and
he thought how wonderful it would be to
build some kind of a device that could
leave the earth and maybe even travel to
Mars watch c-span cities tour today at
2:00 p.m. Eastern on American history TV
on c-span 3 the c-span cities tour
working with our cable affiliates and
visiting cities across the country
professor mends each in your book lost
decades the making of America's debt
crisis and the long recovery how big is
the US debt and who owns it and what do
we mean by own well the u.s. debt is
things like 14 trillion dollars and it's
maybe in terms of publicly held debt
about 70 percent of GDP so if that's how
giving you some perspective it tells you
that you know it's an unprecedented
amount at least in post-war history now
who is it ode to I'd say you know most
of it is owed to other Americans and so
in some sense you can think about it as
we're borrowing from ourselves a sizable
chunk is owed to foreigners of which if
you wanted to you know this being
candidates it'd be the Chinese and you
know various oil exporters what how do
you how do you quantify debt what what
is considered US debt well that's a
complicated question I mean there's most
of the numbers you hear our debt that's
owed by the US government and so that's
actually the number I threw out but
there's a lot of other debt including
debt by households to banks corporations
to other corporations at the financial
institutions and so you know if I were
to add up all that debt it would be sort
of double counting and in fact most of
the time as economists we talk about the
net debt so what's the net debt to the
rest of the world in terms of all
private individuals and the government
and that works out to something like at
the moment
25 percent of GDP now that's a lot but
we probably in and of itself it's not as
problematic as certain times the
question is not net debt you know
netting out what the corporation's owe
each other but the fact that certain
times some corporations and some
households get into trouble and they're
unable to pay their debt and they become
insolvent and so that ripples through
the economy and you can't just say oh
there's a dollar of debt here but it
sold to another person over here and
that sort of all washes out it's those
times that lead to crises when
institutions and households
counted on having assets they've loan
money to somebody and they can't get it
back and corporations or firms have
borrowed money and they can't pay it
back and that results in a real debt
crisis let's talk about public debt when
you talk about the 14 trillion is that
correct of public debt
does that include future Social Security
Medicare payments things like that no it
doesn't it includes just the outstanding
amount of Treasuries that are out there
and in in general what I'm going to do
is sort of net out what's owed between
accounts within the US or the federal
government so it's really just what's
the the debt that's outstanding that's
being held by the public
professor chin what is a Treasury a
Treasury is a is a security or liability
of the federal government that's
directly issued by the US Treasury so
borrowed by the federal government
do you own Treasuries do I own
Treasuries we know if we got if we're
invested in pension fund anything like
that
we're indirectly owning Treasuries it's
likely that they'll hold certain amount
of government Treasuries I don't I think
have anything typically we don't unless
you know you have it in some IRA that's
invested in some other fund maybe you
know a savings bond would be the closest
thing that a lot of us would have seen
the University of Wisconsin does it hold
Treasury that's a good question I
actually don't know probably not not the
university itself but the sort of
retirement system that is that its
employees are invested in all right we
say that the Chinese are buying our debt
what does that mean how does that
operate well the way to think about it
is the Chinese for a long time were
exporting a lot lot more than they were
importing and they would as a country
earn proceeds and most of it was in the
form of dollars okay so they exported a
lot of stuff to the rest of the world
most of the goods they sell are invoiced
in dollars so they get receipts in
dollars and the question then is if
they're earning a lot more from their
exports than they're spending on
imported goods then they're going to
have a pile
foreign-exchange accumulating and you
could keep it in currency but you know
currency gets you zero interest and it's
in practical you know so so what they do
is typically it's held in the form of
Treasuries so when you say or you hear
somebody say that the Chinese hold lots
of Treasuries or they have big dollar
reserves essentially they're saying that
they're holding no dollar assets mostly
in the form of Treasuries because
Treasuries are in some ways the safest
asset in the world you know we haven't
defaulted for a long stretch of time on
on Treasuries the US government and
they're easy to get in and out of the
that is they're highly liquid so in some
sense it's the ideal form in which to
save it and that's why the Chinese and
many oil exporters like Saudi Arabia and
Kuwait wouldn't have their foreign
exchange reserves in the form of
Treasuries as an economist is that a bad
thing for the US I don't think it's
necessarily a bad thing that China holds
them I think it would be a bad thing if
we kept on having the rest of the world
accumulate Treasuries at a rapid pace
because what it means as the US
government is accumulating debt at a
rapid pace now those things those
processes that were under way for a good
chunk of time during the 2000s and even
back into the 1990s they're they're
slowing down so one of the big
earth-shaking things that you don't hear
about very much right now is that China
is actually running down its pile of
foreign exchange reserves that is a
sharp sharp sharp break with what has
happened over the past 15 years and so
we are getting in some sense what we
wanted that the US government is you
know as a share of GDP and as a share of
world GDP accumulating debt of the less
rapid pace but it's also the case where
the rest of the world isn't buying as
many Treasuries as it used to and that
over time has ramifications for the
interest rates will you pay know if
they're buying less of our Treasuries
then relative to anything else the price
of Treasuries will be lower and that's
the same as higher interest rates okay
so there are many offsetting effects
going on at the same time but that's the
tendency if emerging market countries
are including China and oil exporters
tend to
accumulate fewer Treasuries then that's
going to put upward pressure on interest
rates and that's that too has been a
change over the past eight years where
interest rates have including interest
rates on US government debt have been
unnaturally low well the title of your
book is lost decades what happened in
2008 that and how is that rippled well
that's a great question and I think the
the key idea that Jeffrey Frieden my
co-author and I wanted put forward is
that through all this welter of you know
acronyms like CDSs and CDOs and mortgage
backed securities and all these other
terms that we're flying around there's
basically a one single underlying story
that has actually been repeated over and
over again throughout history and that
is that for whatever reasons governments
either encourage or on their own
push through increased borrowing
sometimes it's in the belief that the
times are different and we can manage
that increased borrowing in an efficient
way and a safe way so Alan Greenspan
some time in the mid 2000 said well
we're we're all borrowing much more but
we're in essence a lot smarter than we
used to be we have computer we have
computers to to manage risk we have new
theories about how they deal with risk
we have new derivatives that can help us
manage risk and so the idea that we
could just borrow more is not as scary
as it used to be and I think our view is
that's a very dangerous idea and it's a
particularly dangerous idea because we
get into trouble exactly when we
borrowed a lot and then the environment
changes and a lot of the borrowing that
looked like it was going to be repaid
easily isn't and that's essentially 2008
it's the the household borrowed up to
the hilt because they thought well
housing prices would keep on going up so
it makes sense to borrow the bank's
loaned and they also borrowed financial
institutions borrowed and they were
partly able to evade regulations because
the regulations were outdated with
respect to you know how much you had
to hold in reserve as capital so you had
a combination of financial deregulation
that's the sort of direct government
interventions you had the government
itself embarking on a spending spree
after the 2001 tax cuts we cut taxes get
in 2003 and that encouraged more
borrowing and we had financial
innovation and all these three things
led to increase in borrowing by all
sectors of the economy and it all worked
fantastically to give us this period of
prosperity until of course it didn't
work that is people said oh let's
reassess whether housing prices will
keep on going up oh those securities
that we issued well I don't think
they're worth quite as much as we
thought or the regulator's thought and
the whole system starts unraveling in
Reverse the political response to 2008
Ben Bernanke Henry Paulson Sheila Bair
Presidents Bush and Obama did they get
it right I think once the crisis
unfolded definitely Ben Bernanke and the
Federal Reserve acted correctly and
that's no smart small measure in do to
the part that Bernanke's doctoral theses
had to do with the Great Depression and
the fact that you know he worked out a
new interpretation of why the Great
Depression was so severe and that was
because of the collapse of banking
sector and this view was slightly
actually a big departure from the
dominant view that was associated with
Milton Friedman which had talked about
the monetary influences Bernanke talked
about the credit influences said you
really have to rescue the financial
system to make sure that lending
continues and so I give him a lot of
credit for saving things the Bush
administration did push through a small
stimulus package in 2008 and that
probably helped a bit but really in
terms of fiscal policy tarp which was
the bank bailout was incredibly
important because it reassured people in
the financial sector
along with the Federal Reserve actions
reassured people that the banking system
was going
to continue okay essentially tarp was a
recapitalization of the banking system
the banks had been holding lots of
assets that suddenly were less valuable
than they originally thought
if that happens sufficiently then the
banks are insolvent and they either shut
down or the continuous like zombie Bank
says they didn't Japan for a while and
so you need somebody to come in to
provide funds to make those banks
solvent and that's what the US
government did if it hadn't then I would
think that you know the financial system
would have ground to a halt eventually
it wouldn't not immediately but it would
have stopped lending and you can't run
in finance you can't run an economy
actually without a financial system
that's working
professor Qin our recessions and
economic downturns natural occurrences I
think they're natural occurrences
because you are always going to have a
confluence of events that that strike
economies that we're going to push them
down or up and so cycles are going to
occur you don't want to think the mass
sort of mechanical so you at the moment
you hear about people saying this
recovery is unnaturally long it's longer
than the average and so it must by
definition come to an end my view would
be at some time you know either the
Federal Reserve acts in a way that tips
the economy into recession or some shock
strikes that forces the feds hands or
some shock combination of shocks from
overseas just induces the economy to tip
into a negative growth pattern and so
the big question now I guess there are
two big questions one is you know what
will the Federal Reserve do and will it
be able to manage to just slow the
economy down that's their objective it's
never to just throw the economy into
recession the other question is if the
Federal Reserve is not the thing that
precipitates Moving's recession
is it the combination of world events
and that would be a new event most the
time I think we think about the United
States is moving along on its own path
and not being driven by external
influences if this is a new case where
China and China's slowdown
precipitates a greater slowdown in the
East Asian region which then is
transmitted to the US that would be a
new configuration the world economy was
the legislative response in the last
since 2008 has it been effective some of
the new restrictions some of the new
laws that have been put in place are
they important for stabilization of
economy so I think that they're there
many fold aspects of the legislative
response and no the first one the first
big one was the ARRA the American
Recovery and Reinvestment Act which was
implemented in 2009 and that was a big
counter-cyclical move that is it as the
economy was going down there was an
upward movement from that stimulus and
I'd say that was one of the most
important things to to push the economy
in the right direction otherwise we
could have been mired in a much longer
recession okay that was early on and
most of the effects of that have petered
out but I think that mitigated a lot of
the the the pain and suffering that
could have occurred now the other
innovations or legislation that was
passed I think have more long-lasting
implications and that includes the
dodd-frank legislation regarding banking
regulation and so that's really
important over the longer term in so far
as it really it it reduces the
incentives for banks to over leveraged
that is to borrow up a large amounts
only putting in a little little bit of
their own shareholders money and borrow
up using a sort of short-term financial
market instruments which those are the
two sort of things that got the
financial system into trouble before and
I think with the implementation of
dodd-frank and sort of international
regulations on banking so what are
called on the rubric of Basel three that
you've actually made the banking system
a lot more stable there still remains
some holes in the regulation of the
international financial system and I'd
say that it
now one of the things is we fix problems
in the sectors where we've seen the
problems it's likely that the next
problem we see is someplace that we
didn't expect it or we didn't apply
regulations I mean one way of thinking
about 2008 is you know it wasn't the the
mainline banks that were the big problem
we regulated them in 1930s in response
to the problems of the Great Depression
but then we encountered a whole set of
problems in the shadow' financial system
because individuals and firms and and
banks and other financial institutions
had worked their way around those
regulations or you know here's the term
of financial innovation they had
innovated the way around the regulations
and so we put in the whole set of
regulations now I think it's made the
system safer for a period of time more
robust more stable but people are always
going to be looking around for a way of
evading the regulations so that they can
get a higher rate of return and at the
same time impose the risks upon the
greater financial system and that's the
the hazard that regulators keep on
having to try to keep up with those who
are trying to evade the regulations is
that the message you want people who
read lost the lost decades to take away
the lessons that's exactly one of them
it's that you can't just say we've had
this one big crisis we fix things now
move on history is replete with these
examples where individuals households
firms banks whatever all want to
leverage up because that's a way of
making higher return than you would
otherwise and they want to leverage up
borrow a lot and there's a tendency
because it induces a at least in the
short term a period of buoyant growth
and returns
there's always incentive to say well
there's no trouble there's no problem at
the point at this point if I'm a
politician it's going to land into
somebody else's lap in the future if I'm
a household you might say I'll get out
just before everything crashes or
there's a tendency to say times are
different now we're just smarter or
were more nimble than we used to be the
old rules don't apply and I think our
main point is the old rules to large
extent do still apply if you try to
borrow a lot leverage up a lot then
inevitably some correction will come
round and a lot of pain is going to be
inflicted upon a lot of and many times
innocent bystanders what are you
teaching here at the University of
Wisconsin and what do you want your
students after a semester with you to
leave with so I teach mostly
macroeconomics so international
macroeconomics to both undergraduates in
the Economics Department and I teach
sort of an international macro course
two masters level students in the
LaFollette School of Public Affairs and
the the one thing that I want them to
know is keep alert to read about what's
going on in the world and incorporate
what you've learned in class to
analyzing and why is it that no things
are the way they are why is it that
certain individuals in certain positions
of management in financial firms say
what they say versus what people in
policy positions would say versus what
journalists would say in particular to
use their minds to analyze and dissect
what's being stated and argued rather
than taking for granted you know
somebody says something and because they
look authoritative believe it I want
them to question question everything and
to use their minds to analyze what's
going around going on around them all
right
macroeconomics why can a small country
like Greece mm-hmm affect our giant
economy here in the US
so that's interesting question and it is
let me give you an analogue there was a
interesting statement about the
construction market or construction in
the u.s. leading up to 2008 people would
say well construction of housing only
counts for a small portion of GDP how
can it affect the rest of the economy
and I think what we've learned over the
past eight nine years is
interconnections matter and in in
particular in the case of housing it
wasn't just the actual act of building
housing but it was the fact that people
owned assets that were involved in
housing or houses and that assets were
derived or derivatives had their value
on the basis of housing prices in the
case of Greece lots of private
individuals and had assets that were
issued by the Greek government or issued
by Greece private individuals and so
those holdings lose value as you think
that they're less able to pay and so
there's a big ramification for people's
portfolios there their perceptions of
net wealth that's one instance I'd say
in the case of Greece there was another
set of concerns and one of which is that
the euro was built upon the concept that
no government could default that every
government was going to be embarked upon
a path of sustainable finances okay so
the very fact that a country within the
euro area would get into trouble and
then would have to be bailed out which
is against you know that that's written
out of the the Charter for the eurozone
so that sort of forced a reassessment of
what is possible and if you think about
it it's not just Greece
it's that Greece signals what could
happen to the other periphery countries
so Portugal Italy Ireland Spain you know
those other countries also had problems
with their finances and it's not just
Greece going out but the cig
the grease gives about whether those
countries could also face a similar
problem have to be bailed out and what
that means for the sustainability of the
the single European currency and your
watching book TV on c-span - and we've
been talking with University of
Wisconsin professor Minzy Jim he's the
co-author of this book lost decades the
making of America's debt crisis and the
long recovery Thank You professor
Thank You Patrick Sloan is a Pulitzer
prize-winning journalist he also was a
wire service reporter during the Kennedy
administration he's the author of a new
book called the politics of deception
JFK secret decisions on Vietnam civil
rights in Cuba
what was the kennedy administration like
during its last year well it was all
about politics getting ready for
re-election and he had three major
issues to deal with one was the Cuban
Missile Crisis he was concerned that
Curtis LeMay would tell the truth about
the Cuban Missile Crisis which is bait
what my book is based on is 289 hours of
secret tape recordings kennedy himself
made they were hidden for 34 years but I
listened to all of them along with 16
hours of telephone calls but you can
hear in those tape recordings that
Nikita Khrushchev offered Kennedy a
solution to the Cuban Missile Crisis
essentially a missile swamp get your
missiles out of Turkey and I'll get him
out of Cuba Kennedy said great idea I'll
do it he accepted it within minutes of
Khrushchev's offer so that's that's what
the book tells you that you won't read
elsewhere also on civil rights Kennedy
was very much opposed to Martin Luther
King he was very much opposed to the
civil rights movement one reason is he
got 85 electoral votes from the south in
1960 if he didn't get him Richard Nixon
would have been president so King was an
obstacle for keeping those votes I must
say Linda John
his vice-president told him he said you
won't get those votes the next time
you've got to the ball you got to give
them moral support for the civil rights
movement so kicking and screaming he did
support civil rights of course it'll it
ended up with Johnson doing it on
Vietnam you'll see Kennedy being deeply
involved and what was the overthrow of
the president of South Vietnam and the
likely overthrow and also the
assassination he knew no go did zoom
would be murdered but he didn't do at
the last minute he refused to take steps
to save his life this is all in these
tape recorders
so it's an eye-opener of a book tells
you things you thought you do about
Kennedy I thought I knew about Kennedy I
covered all these topics in 1963 it
isn't until now 50 years later after
listening to these tapes and I found out
what really happened how did you get
access to these tapes
I knew they were available at the
Kennedy Library but they're very hard to
listen to them you know it was low tech
in 1960 63 so you had spent hours you
spent eight hours to get an hour of tape
it was that hard so it was bitter work
I'll tell you many headaches listening
to these things take that telephone
recordings are very good very clear but
some of the the the Kennedy Library held
back on that and the stuff that was most
controversial you know his involvement
in the overthrow of Xion he Newseum
personally he was the original booster
of Zia to be president via
defended him while he was a senator but
you remember the bunk immolated himself
on the streets of Vietnam that picture
changed Kennedy changes the whole
situation in Vietnam it was just a
matter of time before Kennedy got rid of
it from what you gathered on the tapes
and where the Kennedy administration was
going into its its second second term
what do you think it would have looked
like it had to come to completion well
Mike Mansfield who was a Senate
Democratic leader I dealt with him quite
a bit
he assured me that Kennedy would
withdraw from Vietnam but Bobby Kennedy
also a senator assured me Kennedy would
never pull out of Vietnam now I believe
Vance me but I think the and according
to Mike Kennedy told him at one point I
can't do it now in 63 I have to get
reelected in 1964 after that then I'll
withdraw a phased withdrawal but events
what once he overthrew the president of
Vietnam that government collapsed within
weeks the the Vietnamese military
collapsed so it was it ended up you know
Kennedy was killed 20 days after zoom
was killed
so Lyndon Johnson gets handed the
totally collapsed government an army of
South Vietnam and eventually he made his
own decisions
about sending American combat troops but
Johnson went to his grave Kay arguing
that Kennedy's assassin or overthrow an
assassination of Zia Johnson was a big
supporter of Zinn was the reason
he ended up committed combat troops
Patrick's lion is a Pulitzer
prize-winning journalist he's the author
of the new book the politics of
deception JFK secret decisions on
Vietnam civil rights in Cuba published
by Thomas Dunne books thanks so much
good evening again welcome to the
Library of Virginia I'm happy to
introduce tonight's distinguished author
former governor Wilder who as you heard
has a new memoir entitled son of
Virginia a life in America's political
arena as noted I'm Andrew Kane on the
state politics editor at the Richmond
times-dispatch and I'm proud to be in
sort of what's become a select
fraternity of Virginia political
reporters who first encountered Doug
Wilder back in 1985 thirty years ago
when he was barnstorming the state as
part of his historic campaign for
lieutenant governor and back then I was
one of two reporters at a little
newspaper in Luray Virginia up in the
Shenandoah Valley and I remember
distinctly this day in 1985 where the
door burst open and Doug Wilder bounds
in with his son and chauffeur Larry in
tow and it just goes to show you that he
was and is a force of nature
but this grandson of slaves was a public
figure in Virginia years before his
first historic run for statewide office
the first black member of the Virginia
Senate since reconstruction he served in
the state Senate for 16 years before he
was elected lieutenant governor becoming
the first african-american elected to
statewide office in Virginia of course
four years later he followed that up in
1989 when he became the nation's first
elected african-american governor as
governor Doug Wilder guided the state
through a difficult recession a Democrat
he briefly sought his party's 1992
presidential nomination then years later
in 2004
he became the first popularly elected
mayor of the city of Richmond in more
than 50 years
governor Wilders memoir is filled with
rich details and revealing reflections
on his historic journey razed and
segregated Churchill in the city of
Richmond the son of loving and dignified
parents graduated from Virginia Union
University in 1951 with a degree in
chemistry he served in the Army during
the Korean War and received a Bronze
Star for his heroism in the book
governor Wilder gives harrowing details
of combat and how it resonates with him
to this day he writes about how after
fighting for Koreans freedom he came
home and he had to leave Virginia in
order to find a law school that would
accept an african-american he notes that
he might have become bitter but for a
seminal event the US Supreme Court's
decision in Brown versus Board of
Education renewed his faith in America
and set him on a path toward a career in
law after earning a law degree at
Washington's Howard University he
established a law practice in Richmond
in 1969 he won a special election for
state Senate and the rest truly is
history in his inaugural address as
governor in January 1990 he proclaimed I
am a son of Virginia the memorable line
that is echoed in his memoirs title
today the former governor still speaks
forthrightly on issues of social justice
race and equality and he continues to
work toward his goal of a national
slavery Museum as we say in the news
business he's been good copy for 45
years
ladies and gentlemen will you please
join me in welcoming governor Wilder to
the podium thank you thank you so much
thank you it's particularly good to be
here
Andy and I do remember bonds darling and
bringing into your place in Newry I say
to some of the people and I see some of
the legislators here Ken plumb is here
and I got to be very careful as to what
I say because he'll tell you whether it
was true or not
but one of the things I say to people
when they want to run for office
particularly in Virginia our deference
to your present position as the larger
newspaper with the RTD but if you want
to get coverage go to the local papers
go to the local radio stations those
people read those papers and they listen
to those stations and I made it a point
and they're always available I and it
doesn't cost you anything I made it a
point whenever I travel to make certain
I knew where that station was and called
before we got there and sure enough you
can stay on for as long as you'd like so
it's good to be here and I look out over
the audience I see people who served in
my cabinet so quite a few of them and I
served in the legislature with and I
served in the numbers of various
capacities and my former law partner is
here Judge Gregory who's got to leave a
little earlier he's got to listen to
some cases I guess but
it's just a fascinating thing for me to
be I see one of my good friends come
from the junior state but nevertheless a
good man the thing I also liked about
this library is I think I had a little
bit to do with it and it has meant a lot
I see all the good friends here and it
the librarian at the time who conceived
much of the ideas for this to take place
was a person of color fine young man he
died earlier and that's why I was saying
to someone earlier today the good
fortune in life is to be able to get up
in the morning and the better fortune is
to then know who you are and I've been
so lucky so lucky all this time sort of
do it so I want to talk briefly about a
few things in the book and then turn it
over to your questions as you would have
them one of the things that Andy Andrew
Kane spoke of was so true and I I did a
radio interview with some Florida people
this morning and they got into the
Veterans Bay peace and the fact that I
was a veteran and I it made me have a
strong recollection because that did so
much for me in more ways than one not
just coming back and seeing what took
place in 1954 but as I said returning
home from the war was bittersweet and
I'm reading from Chapter three I was
alive but the truth of my circumstances
became depressingly clear I had been
called to fight for the freedom of a
people when I did not have that same
freedom I could not sit where I wanted
to sit eat where I wanted to eat walk
where I wanted to walk and the doors of
America's greatest institutions were
closed to me
and yet the military service did so much
for me first of all the army had been
integrated this was the first time that
people of color were able to be soldiers
not black soldiers on purple or red or
green and it was my real first
experience in terms of meeting with
knowing to the extent of sleeping in the
same buildings being in the same mess
halls eating from the same plates on
some occasions particular in combat and
sharing the same experiences so it was
just such a it's almost like another
world so you know in a minute Virginia
in Richmond is this and yet here we're
doing these kinds of things it was
almost like an out-of-body experience
you say okay I'm back now and yet what
it taught me that the possibilities of
it wait a minute this can happen in the
military why can't it happen
everywhere in America and so when I came
back from the military my degree was in
chemistry and I started working as a
chemist not right away he didn't want to
do anything right away my mother said
are you going to do something I said
well yes I am
and I was I was having a ball I'd save
my money I'd sent it home and soon I got
there the first thing I did I bought a
car she said what do you guys said the
money that I sent here paid cash for it
oh you first call anybody my family ever
bought keep people cash don't wanting
the bills because I didn't have a job
but I was getting my little check and
but I was still just having a ball
having a ball having a ball and
ultimately I did get a an opportunity to
go to Virginia State thinking about
working ISM getting a master's in
chemistry that didn't work I have stayed
in that class for about a month this
ain't me so I got out of there and came
to work in the state medical examiner's
office and in that process I was doing
all of the drunk driving test for the
state of Virginia I was doing the
toxicology determining the causes of
death and I felt so important putting on
my white jacket going into MCV pulling
up the cadaver and put that person they
would pull him up put him on and I stick
the pipette in his heart pull it up see
how much blood I could get to determine
whether that person drowned in salt
water or fresh water
if the burning was in they've had boxing
globin was in it long or was it somebody
they had been burnt after they'd been
shot and yet it wasn't doing it for me
and then when the Brown versus Board of
Education decision came down it was
lingering with me for some while and
when it did hit I said you mean to tell
me that nine white men have decided that
they were wrong that 1896 Plessy versus
Ferguson was wrong and that there's no
such animal that's separate but equal
Wow
so this system just might work
even though I've given up on it given up
on it started reading all sorts of wild
things and people that my and my mother
I would keep her up half the night after
I would come in from running around and
we would talk all night into the morning
and and she was still saying you can do
this you can do that you can do the
other
and so what bothered me was the as I say
coming back to Virginia
facing what some of the people were
doing with the committee to stop the
integration of the schools laws
concerning school attendance should be
amended so that no child will be
required to attend an integrated school
funds should be allowed kated at tuition
grants so even after brown all of this
was taking place and it got so that I
knew that I had to do something
different so I then was fortunate enough
to get some nice lawyers here the right
letters at Howard University to take a
chance on me to go to law school and I
was very much interested in it and I
thought that practicing law was just
running in mouths the smartest lawyers
in the world don't do too much talk and
they think and then they might talk
after they think but I was fortunate
enough then after I came back to
Richmond to have got a telephone call
from Spotswood Robinson and he said you
know I I understand you got your own
office over in Churchill and I said yeah
he said would you be interested in
helping me a little would I be
interested in helping you I can't wait
and he said well I don't have that much
space in my office then that's why I've
inquired as to whether you have yours
well it worked to the extent that I
started working with him on cases and he
was such a taskmaster that he just was
very impressive
and he said to me maybe about after a
year he said I am got some news I've
been asked to be the Dean at the Howard
School of Law and how would you what do
you think about it I said I think it's
good news and bad news he said what do
you mean I says good news for you but
bad news
I don't want to lose this opportunity to
work with you he said well I'll tell you
what he said I am the registered agent
for the n-double-a-cp legal defense and
education fund in Virginia and Thurgood
Marshall and he were just like that
he said if they're good marceline
surrogates coming down next week I'd
like you to meet him and I'm going to
ask him to appoint you to take my place
to be the registered agent well it ain't
fun that's what they call it that's the
one that's incorporated that's the money
funder the n-double-a-cp which means
your name will be on all of the papers
you will be meeting all of these civil
rights lawyers around the country and
you will be participating in the cases I
said you you think that he would do that
he said I'm gonna ask him so sure enough
they're good came in town the next week
we met at a place on Second Street
slaughters was the name of the place
that's why everybody met that's where
everybody stayed and very good at a
cigar in his mouth but yay long and he
looked down at me there's about six
three or four he says what's tell me he
wants to recommend you to take his place
I said yes sir he said sit down it's
done let's have some lunch oh wow
Wow well what does that do for me it
made it made me I wasn't a civil rights
lawyer because I wanted to have my own
separate law practice period across the
board but it made me have to be a part
of every civil rights case that was
handled by the n-double-a-cp legal
defense and education fund and so I was
able to meet Thurgood and Jack Greenberg
and Bob Carter and Trudeau from Illinois
and Bob Ming from
I mean Trudeau from Louisiana Bob Ming
from Chicago Jack Young from Mississippi
I could go down the line and they will
have the Moot Court arguments at Howard
getting ready to go to the Supreme Court
and so with the military experience that
I had and then the opportunity to work
with spot and to learn what was going on
that that started me and I had a a good
law practice so matter of fact I had a
great law practice and politics was the
last thing I wanted to get involved with
except I kept running my mouth all the
time I would run my mouth and people
would say okay fine then I would run my
mouth some more and they were say well
why don't you run they didn't mean run
far I was immune run away stop talking
all the time and I I didn't want to go
around asking for votes and smiling and
grinning shaking hands and begging for
money but I found out you you can't
criticize from the outside unless you're
willing to be a part of the inside and
to make things happen it's not a matter
of your doing it for you I was
everything I've ever done people told me
I couldn't do it you can't open an
office in church here why they've never
had a law office in Churchill now not a
black nor white
nobody has ever had a law office in
Churchill I said that's why I'm going
because I know these two thirds with the
pee
by the first name and I never had a
short period in times of but my practice
was late but what involved my getting to
politics was the fact that everything
was predictable you can't run why
because it's not ready well you can't do
this because there's not time and once I
started seeing the voter registration
lines taking place particularly after
the Lindland on Lyndon Johnson election
in 1968 when people are standing in line
for blocks to vote I say wait a minute
here something's gotta change
we got to do something yes so I started
meeting with people talking about who we
could run for various offices and we did
run a young lawyer from Richmond Ronald
really
Clarence Newsom was his name died very
young but he came very close but he
didn't win because the process wasn't as
it should be so I formed my own little
voting group to the consternation of the
existing group which was the most
powerful group that was a crusade for
voters and and yet I wanted to be
certain that we had a voter education
and registration aspect to let people
know why they're voting what they're
voting for when they should vote not
just vote because we say vote vote
because it's in your interest to vote if
these are the things that should come
well it did get down to the point where
I saw the opportunities to run I never
wanted to run for a two-year term
running to every year you got to go out
in campaign and so when Ferger reed was
elected to the House of Delegates
becoming the first African American
elected to the House of Delegates and
since reconstruction and I knew then
that the possibilities could take place
bill Thornton was president the crusade
the voters at the time and he could have
been elected but they chose to have a
different form of endorsement
consequently even he didn't run so two
years later I said the guy who was
running to be governor to be I'm sorry
lieutenant governor was J sergeant
Reynolds I said well if size runs is
gonna run for lieutenant governor he's
gonna win
consequently I'm gonna plan my campaign
right now and as soon as he wins I'm
going to open up my office and sure
enough that's the way it happened
everybody wasn't happy with it no one
usually is but I've always been guided
by the thing that the thing is right at
the time is right the thing is right and
in this instance that thought it was
right so I ran for that office and was
elected and I my mother was still living
and I was so pleased that she was and
she said to me on that night as we were
standing at a building him second and
carry
second and Franklin Street don't let
your head get too big and I've never
forgotten that and yet when the time
came to determine whether I would go
further I stayed as you said end of 16
years in the Senate I chaired most of
the committees I had even gotten to be
the chairman of the steering committee
which is the committee that appoints
other senators to serve and so if you
had if you want to serve on the
committee I may have had a little bit to
do with it and a little bit to do what
you're not serving too
and that's what the political pictures
about quid pro quo why is it that I've
always got to do for you and you never
for me bobby's God said this a couple of
three weeks or so ago when he had a
symposium here he said never could
understand Doug Wilde as a vote when we
were serving in the Senate together he
said you're gonna vote for this measure
aren't you I said why do you say that he
said you've always supported it and I
said yeah that's true I always have he
said what it's getting ready to come out
didn't look like it was that bad in it
and the committee I said that's correct
he said what are you gonna do I said why
don't we just wait and see
sure enough guy Campbell who was a
sponsors of the bill that's Bobby
mr.brother he was going to support it
doesn't that Bobby said well I'm just
gonna wait and see and then Bobby
ultimately had voted for it and it
passed by a narrow margin but Bobby says
from that time on he could never ever
not depend on this guys for his vote
because the guys said you got so you
need some help on that Scotty I fine I
said well that's what I mean by quid pro
quo that's why I said at the time I've
been here 16 years I don't want a medal
for the longest serving senator in the
history of Virginia consequently I'm
either going to move up or out done all
I can do here and as fortune would have
it I did run from the Lieutenant
Governor ship and as Andy Cain has
pointed out I did travel the state the
most beautiful experience I had I took
60 days straight and said I was going to
go to every city and county and Virginia
not on the interstates by the country
roads and I want to shake the hands and
meet the people I'm not going to stay in
any hotels or motels the only places I
will stay will be in the homes of the
people that I've met
people that I've known or that I knew
and I that's 60-day period of time 1985
I never encountered a single person that
refused to shake my hand refuse to
accommodate me to give me an audience
never denied entrance to any place at
all and it hit me that this was the
Virginia that I always knew about and
read about in terms of what Patrick
Henry had to say I lived only seven
blocks away from st. John's Church and I
would go there as a boy and they Stewart
mr. Spencer rang wrong was a friend of
my family's and he think he always got
great tips from the people that were
there and he was always kind to me
always give me a nickel and I would
stand on the street waiting for him to
come by my mother said you're begging
for mr. wrong and when you think about
what Patrick Henry had to say there when
I read about the Declaration of
Independence and would ask my mother all
men are created equal and they are
endowed by that cretur with certain
inalienable rights and that life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness does that
mean me she said yes absolutely
I say well then something wrong she said
no it means you the streetcar lines
ended one block from where I lived which
means if you got on the streetcar to go
someplace
it wasn't have a full because you at the
end of the line and so we would get on
and she would say come on at school and
that sit at the front she then let's go
back a little further
okay one more not for them well I wasn't
evil to read the colored and white side
and I would say and she said and then
when I did see sometimes the conductor
asking people to move back oh she would
say to me is this will change this will
change you just come on use it you just
sit back here and then one thing and
that I write about in the book that she
and I would discuss and I was greatly
impressed with the Greek philosophers
and I said Socrates she said yes
Socrates says no you're right
then proceed and that's stuck with me
in other words once you make up your
mind as to what is right and once you
have that determined and I'm not
speaking about the legality but I'm
speaking about the substance of what
you're doing and that force once that
happens then you move from there and she
said after you have determined that
you're right
don't change it just for anyone else's
sake not even for me if you were
convinced and then that caused me again
to question other things and that is why
when we are in a state like Virginia why
can't I be the lieutenant governor and
what's wrong with it and the people of
Virginia said so I carried Southwest
Virginia can you imagine in a Democrat
to date I can say he carries Southwest
Virginia in a time